FOR NEWS ALL THE TIME.
FOX NEWS.COM.
I AM GETTING A HEADS UP IN MY
EAR.
SOMETHING IS GOING ON.
LAURA IS UP TO SOMETHING.
LET NOT YOUR HEART BE TROUBLED.
"THE INGRAHAM ANGLE" IS NOW.
>> Laura: WELL, WE JUST
CELEBRATED OUR FIFTH
ANNIVERSARY.
THIS IS LIKE THE CHER'S FAREWELL
CONCERT.
SHE NEVER RETIRED.
MY GREAT CRACK PRODUCERS PUT
TOGETHER A TRIBUTE IT 5 YEARS OF
CROSSTALK WITH SEAN HANNITY.
>> Sean: NO, NO.
>> Laura: LET IT ROLL.
>> Sean: YOU HAVE TO BE PREPARED
FOR THE HAND OFF.
>> Laura: AMERICA, THIS IS THE
"HANNITY" STRIP TEASE.
YOU DO A LIVE RAP THROW TO ME.
>> Sean: HANG ON ONE SECOND.
I WILL BE RIGHT.
THERE I AM WALKING TO THE NEXT
STUDIO.
THIS IS HOW CLOSE I AM TO YOU.
[LAUGHING].
>> Laura: MAKE SURE THE LIGHTING
IS SHADOWIY.
I AM GLAD YOU HAVE A TIE ON.
IS THIS GOING TO BE A STRIP
TEASE EVERY NIGHT?
>> Sean: IT'S NOT A STRIP TEASE.
>> Laura: TAKE THE HOUR I CAN'T
DO IT.
>> Sean: WE LOST LAURA'S SINGLE.
I AM A TALK SHOW HOST AND I
NEVER SHUT UP.
>> Laura: I AM BACK.
NO STRIP TEASE.
DOESN'T LOOK LIKE IT.
[LAUGHING].
WE ARE OUT.
>> Sean: GOOD NIGHT.
>> Laura: WOW.
LACK OUT TOM JONES.
[LAUGHING].
-- LOOK OUT.
THAT'S FOR THE REALLY OLD CROWD.
SAMANTHA NOTICED YOU HAD THE
SAME YELLOW TIE ON TONIGHT THAT
YOU WERE WEARING 4 YEARS AGO.
[LAUGHING].
THANK GOD YOU THREW IT OFF IN
THE MIDDLE.
>> Sean: CAN I SAY ONE SERIOUS
THING?
YOU HAD 5 UNBELIEVABLE, AMAZING
YEARS HERE ON FOX.
WE ARE SO PROUD OF YOU.
YOU ARE A CRITICAL PART OF OUR
TEAM.
IT IS A TEAM HERE AT FOX.
YOUR SHOW IS SO SUCCESSFUL.
WE ARE PROUD OF YOU AND HAPPY
FOR YOU.
HERE'S FOR ANOTHER 15 YEARS.
HOW MANY MORE YEARS WILL WE KEEP
DOING THIS?
>> Laura: I DON'T KNOW.
WHEN YOU ARE NICE IT'S HARD TO
REACT.
THANK YOU.
IT MAKES IT FUN.
WE LOST THE TIE.
YOU ARE A FRUGAL PERSON SO IT'S
THE SAME TIE 4 YEARS AGO.
I LIKE THAT.
SEAN, GREAT SHOW TONIGHT